الحاجه اللي بنادي بها جدا ان نظام
يبص للتعليم
لا تشبه نهايتها على الاطلاق
اشهر رجل اعمال في صناعه السيارات لم يبدا
حياته مهندسا او صناعيا
بالقضاء سبع سنوات من عمره في دراسه الطب
الى ان تخرج من جامعه عين شمس عام
1976 ثم غير مسار حياته تماما حين قرر
العمل في شركه عائلته المتخصصه في تجاره
قطاع غيار السيارات
وبعد تسع سنوات بدات تاسيس مجموعه شركات
غبور
في البدايه احتل مكانه مرموقه في قطاع
الاطارات داخل الشبكه
كبار اللاعبين في صناعه السيارات في
المنطقه
حصل الغبور على عقود التوزيع الحصري
للعلامات التجاريه للشركات العالميه
للسيارات وطور على مدار سنوات الماضيه
اعمال شركه جي بي اوتو حتى اصبحت من اكبر
شركات تجميع وتوزيع السيارات في الشرق
الاوسط
فلازم لازم نبتدي نفكر
بره الصندوق بره السوق المصري لازم نفكر
في ان احنا ننشئ مصانع بغرض
التوزيع السوق المحلي ولا اسواق
المنطقه القديمه
من اعماله نصف مليون جنيه لا اكثر ليتوسع
بعد ذلك وتصل استثمارته الى 30 مليار جنيه
على 20 20 قصيده غبور بالسرطان وكانت هذه
المعركه التي لم ينقط فيها الطب
اخر اعلان من رؤوف غبور قبل وفاته كان بيع
حصته الشخصيه المباشره في جي بي اوتو
مقابل واحد وثلاثين مليون جنيه تقريبا
[موسيقى]
اقتصاديات الجدول العالميه لسنه السيارات
اللي هي بتبدا من 200 الف عربيه
[موسيقى]